president biden and vladimir putin
getting ready for their rumble it's a
high-stakes summit tomorrow
biden is promising to hold russia
accountable and confront putin
but all of a sudden his tough talk of
the past has turned to praise watch
you know vladimir putin you think he's a
killer
i do he's bright he's tough
and i have found that he is a
uh as they say when he used to play ball
a worthy adversary
so which one is it richard uh you know i
think he's the word the absolutely also
authoritarian can i command it for not
cannot pronounce the word today
authoritarian um
but i also you know listen going into
this one i think we've talked about the
media's beat the story to death
when this this summit but i do think
that uh i'm giving
a lot of hope to biden that he's going
to get this right no president's been
able to get this right um
most presidents have failed uh at
creating
administration after administration
nobody can get this guy right so maybe
the idea of having a singular press
conference of putin can't upstage you
or steal your sound bite or steal your
thunders or you can't embarrass yourself
that part because we saw that happen
with donald trump when he had his and we
saw that with joe biden repeatedly
at the g7 uh i don't know about that
olivia
syria really wandering into the i don't
know about that i think i think i guess
they all look alike right
joe i think that joe biden's gonna do a
great job he's been on the scene for a
number of years he's served as a vice
president for eight years he has a
firsthand seat to how this thing could
be done what went wrong
what went right and i think he has the
opportunity to get it right by calling
out russia's military buildup by calling
out the cyber attacks and by calling out
the high red warfare that we see russia
engaging in in eastern europe so i do
think you know putin's going to say it's
going to say no we didn't do it prove it
of course he's going to say that but
that's the reason why you don't have a
joint press conference with them
yeah well i don't know man there were
not high expectations the first time
president trump
met with putin in fact people said that
you know he's a russian asset
and putin is the great puppet master
who's really controlling
the trump administration why is biden
getting a pass here
well i think what trump understood is
what reagan understood and bush 41
and and even clinton understood is that
when it comes to these high-stakes
one-on-one
summits a lot of this is personal
relationship
and you can insult the country you
insult the leader
that makes things tough so it looks like
joe biden has a little bit of what i
call imposter syndrome
i know it because i have it it's it's
kind of an insecure feeling that you're
not worthy of the job you have
i see joe biden kind of grappling with
the fact that
wait a second i'm the leader of the free
world here
and two months ago i called this guy a
killer
and i'm on the eve of a big diplomatic
meeting maybe i should soften this up
after i have to sit down with him for
four hours
it's all like it's happening in real
time he seems uncomfortable
on the world stage what i think the
american people care about
is not some dissident that no one can
pronounce his name
disappeared or something like that i get
that that's important for my family
right now very important i forget that
that's actually pretty critical
for the american people i think the
american people care about the hacks
that jacked their gas prices up
and the hacks on big beef that screwed
up the barbecue
that's what the american people care
about the most and you want to see the
president
confront the leader of russia on those
issues and actually do something
afterwards that has some teeth
why no bilat i mean this is your
wheelhouse you hate that
press conference yes why no bilateral
press conference with i mean
white house explanation is that they
didn't want to give putin an
international platform but by agreeing
to a summit
or suggesting a summit you gave him an
international platform so
i don't really buy that um i i i you
have to wonder if they
thought that it might not be good to
have them on stage together
um because you know joe biden might call
him a killer but
it's like being a twitter troll yeah
right and then like but face to face
like you would never say that to
somebody's face
unless you mean it i don't know how
they're gonna meet for four and a half
hours four to five hours like what are
you gonna talk about for four to five
hours that's a really long time
i think that they'll come out of it with
some sort of thing where they can agree
on
a climate change something or other and
the media will swoon
and everyone will be so pleased but he
has to come out of it with something on
the ransomware yeah he has to because
that's actually affecting real people
plus there are americans who are being
held unjustly absolutely in addition to
alexi navalny
that issue but there are americans who
are being held unjustly and if biden
could actually get something done there
that would
that would be and they're talking about
a prisoner swap so we'll see if that
happens what's the most important thing
to tackle at the summit oh well i think
the big
the big story we learned is that jessie
waters has impostor syndrome
i mean that's like i don't know why that
isn't good that is our lead tomorrow and
i'm writing that monologue
unless you have imposter imposter
syndrome where you're faking that you
have imposters yeah
that's more like it yeah so look here
the problem the problem with biden
president biden is you don't know where
he's coming from
and you don't know where he's going much
like himself and you would the contrast
is with
you always knew where donald trump was
coming from he had two words america
first
and i think with joe biden it's you know
america will see
i don't even know and you kind of notice
the trend when you're looking in the
rear view mirror
that a lot of stuff trump did that now
doesn't seem as impulsive
as it was before that maybe he actually
knew what he was doing
like how to be how to be socially
amenable with dictators and then behind
the scenes
go after them and work something out i
think that the one lesson is we're such
a lucky country that we can endure
and even survive not because of our
leadership but in spite of our
leadership
because we put people in this job that
clearly
he's not up to it you know biden can
bumble through this thing
with these long frightening pauses and
we have to sit there quietly and go holy
hell what's going on
that pause that went on forever and
meanwhile god forbid trump held his
glass of water with two hands or
shuffled down a ramp that slippery ramp
and everybody went ballistic
but by acts like mr magoo on magic
mushrooms
and we all have to say oh you know
nothing to see here is there a baseball
game on
because it's boring are they going to
ask for transcripts like they did in the
calls with putin and trump
yeah i don't know i don't know that's a
good question
to take the transcripts this time around
than the last time it was a perfect call
well he said so they say russian nesting
doll that's back at the ranch
president trump uh coming up next uh hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else